und ist jetzt carry und media sophie
kann man wenn man da richtig antwortet
zwei youtube freundin armen leute das
leben als youtube ist manchmal gar nicht
so leicht ihr müsst verstehen leute ich
sitze hier machen meine videos für euch
und es macht mir spaß was wirklich spaß
euch zu unterhalten aber irgendwas fehlt
irgendwas stimmt nicht an dieser
gesamten rechnung irgendwas brauche ich
in meinem leben vollständig zu machen
oder sich da letztens darüber
nachgedacht habe ist es mir eingefallen
ich brauche youtube freundin das ist die
lösung leute alles macht zu zweit viel
mehr spaß man kann zusammen videos
aufnehmen zusammen wir schneiden und
eine frage stellt sich dabei nur wer ist
mein youtube freundin legen wir los wir
finden wer das passende youtuber geld
für mich ist und ich würde fast sagen
wir schreiben die person am ende des
videos einfach mal an übrigens lukat
auch letzten zum video gemacht habe ich
euch unten verlinkt hat der glaube ist
ein youtube freund gesucht ich habe von
meinen vorschlägen gesehen aber arbeitet
und ähnliches video wahrscheinlich erst
habe ich euch das modden verlinkt
welcher charakter trifft am besten auf
dich zu cool und witzig verrückt und
liebt schillig und selbstbewusst beliebt
und nett lustig und humorvoll so beliebt
kann man schon mal ausschließen ich
würde jetzt noch verrückt und lieb sagen
was ist er den klamotten style schön und
lässig modern und offen hübschen trend
süß und kuschelig und gemütlich auch
hier muss man sagen der klamotten style
höchstwahrscheinlich ja nicht so gut zu
mir chillig aber auch nicht ich glaube
ich bin nicht jemand der so gastiert ich
will wirklich doch keinen sinn antworten
und ich will genau die richtige antwort
heraus bekommen weil wenn ich mich schon
blamieren und der person 100 auch
schreibe dann sollte so die richtige
sein ich würde sagen schön und lässt
sich ganz heimlich rumlaufe aber so ein
bisschen schilliger berichte schon ein
alter
muss ich das jetzt wirklich sagen was
hast du für eine schlechte seite
wirklich an gewaltig pünktlichkeit alter
dumm heißt nervensäge kann man auch
mittlere sache angesetzt also auf jeden
fall bin ich nicht der allerbeste das
muss ich ehrlich sagen dumm
also ich gehe auf jeden fall von euch
mal voll viele nachrichten wo er sagt
dass ich dumm wäre und hässlich und das
ich stinke größte community kleine pizza
zecke kann ich aber ausschließen ich bin
ich nicht zickig aber leute ich noch
nicht einmal nicht zu sehr selbst fertig
denn wenn ich meinen youtube freundin
beeindrucken will die dieses video
vielleicht ja sogar sieht dann muss ich
jetzt coole darüber reden über kommen
und youtube von den sitzen
aber ich würde jetzt noch sagen
angeberisch oh mein gott oh mein gott
denkst du gerne beziehungsweise oft
alter den ganzen fucking tag das geht so
weit dass leute mit denen ich unterwegs
bin mich fragen sind kannst du nicht
einfach mal die schnauze halten bei mir
ist es so ich habe prinzipiell immer nur
rum und diese norm muss ich auch immer
singen und zwar den ganzen tag lang klar
oder musik ist mein leben 1000 prozent
hinbekommen was wir gerade aufhält ja
vermehrt auf ist wahrscheinlich
fortschritte merkel hätte ich doch
dummheit ankreuzen sollen bei dem
fallschirm rad immer so die youtuber
sein um die es geht bist du auf der alle
länder mit diesen kontinenten eigentlich
nicht ich denke mal immer super
der videos für euch machen was soll ich
diese handbewegung war wirklich er es
geht
schmilzt du dich oft
[Musik]
auf jeden fall wobei ich würde eher
sagen wie viel lust ich habe weil ich
habe eigentlich keine lust mich zu
spenden bist du eher groß oder klein
yes leute jetzt kann ich meine stärke
ausspielen ich hoffe da kann ich punkten
ich hoffe meine youtube hollenstedt auf
größere jungs oder weil aber ich wäre
191 so kann natürlich auch sein dass
sich also auf 131 große männer steht
groß für mein alter würde ich sagen dass
kelly übrigens heute fragt sag ich jetzt
mal so offen für alle die bisherige
geschaut haben quasi als belohnung für
euch meine es ist ein mythos dass meine
familie meine kleine schwester kam zu
mir breit gemeint sebastian du musst mit
kelly zusammenkommen ich hab kein wort
mit ihr darüber verloren dass ich mit
irgendwelchen zusammenkommen oder so sie
meist so sebastian du musst mit kelly
zusammenkommen alles klar was findet im
wichtigsten familien freunde ehrlichkeit
im abenteuer gesundheit und zusammen
spaß und freundschaft liebe und glück
spaß und freude also familie ist mir
auch mega wichtig aber doch familie ist
familie für die familie
was hast du von talenten spontaneität
kreativität modebewusstsein lustigkeit
singen und tanzen ich glaube leute wenn
ich jetzt lustigkeit ein kreuz
man weiß wie die kommentare aussehen
werden alle er hatte sogar den treuesten
zuschauer schreien so h
sie war es denn du willst nicht lustig
beste community deswegen will die
zusagen spontanität ich bin kein
spontaner mensch was hältst du von dir
selbst bisschen verrückt sein schadet
nie auf jeden fall was denken andere
über dich deutet das geht jetzt an euch
raus ich habe die kommentare welche von
diesen optionen am nächsten zu mir passt
süß und schön selbstbewusst und
hilfsbereit nett und witzig hübsch und
cool verrückt und lustig würde am ersten
tagen verrückt und lustig und ist jetzt
carry und media so viel kann man wenn
man da richtig antwortet zwei youtube
freundin haben
[Musik]
hast du einen freund ja jeder hat doch
ein freund oder freundin ok jetzt wird's
spannend was guckst du am meisten auf
youtube youtube changes geben und marx
musik und comedy youtube und live musik
und comedy auf jeden fall da ist in der
kälte ich will dass kinder ohne wird
jedes mal wenn ich bild von pellisier
denke ich an meine kleine schwester
stelle ich das mal vor ihr seid youtuber
machst du eure videos und eine schwester
kommt zu ihnen sagt sebastian du hast es
kurze schnauze ich bestimmt mal dass du
mit der youtube zusammen kommst da sagt
man als großer bruder nichts mehr was
würdest du hauptsächlich für videos
hochladen komme uk blogs chats und blogs
beauty und lifestyle
dann kommen wir den effekt jetzt sogar
das wichtige frage leute was sollten
youtuber für dich sein humorvoll lustig
verrückten aufgedreht nett und witzig
selbstbewusst und coop schon süß
selbstbewusst und cool und jetzt leute
ich hoffe es eine person der ich schon
kontrakt habe mit hält mich schon mal
geschrieben haben weil wenn es so anders
ist
ich würde den kalender schreiben ich
kenne das ist freilich auch zu mir passt
der ebit ihr beide seid mega talentiert
und seit das zu negativ musik ist ihr
leben und ihr seite teilt beliebt danke
du liebst eines esels über alles und das
sieht man klar leute jeder der main
kanal verfolgt weiß dass ich meine
taktisch gemüse lieber alter soll ich
jetzt wirklich schon berlins schreiben
bei gleicher es war so green day mit 4,2
millionen follower dann schreiben wir
mal eine nachricht und das schreibe ich
jetzt auch schon david schreiben damit
die meine youtube freuen wird
ich habe da kann eigentlich nichts mehr
schief gehen oder
da hab ich dieses video auch zu einer
leute vertrauen in die kommentare ob ihr
ernsthaft denken wird das green day wird
nicht zusammenpassen würden ihr könnt
ihr jetzt auch eine neue
was viel abdecken da gibt es noch mehr
videos von mir und von anderen menschen
und diesen lustig und vielleicht eine
von ihm mit schönen david zusammen
irgendwann so oder so jetzt folgen bis
zunächst mal macht's gut und zeigt sein